and the Ageless one LeBron James
greatest scorer of all time and the
greatest shooter of all time s howdy I
love seeing all these guys Embrace and
talk after these games well I'd like to
see those two together in Paris
representing the United States steps
first Olympics and LeBron kind of
leading the charge yeah the Avengers Jo
and be playing for Team USA Steve C the
coach Kevin Durant yeah they're trying
to they don't like what happened in the
World Cup now
no that's uh Lebron and and one of my
favorites but Kevin Durant's Phoenix
media day I will be there in Paris and
Brandon psky we were bragging about you
the whole